[Musique]
tout homme portant lui une valeur
fondamentale et inaliénable et pourtant
9 millions 2 de personnes vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté dans notre pays
vivre sous le seuil de pauvreté c'est
environ 1000 euros par mois
parmi ces 9 millions 2 de personnes
2 millions plus de 2 millions de
personnes vivent dans la grande pauvreté
et sans jamais vouloir opposer les unes
aux autres
vivre dans la grande pauvreté ce n'est
pas un accident de la vie vivre dans la
grande pauvreté ça n'arrive pas du jour
au lendemain c'est à voir
accumule de précarité c'est à dire vous
avez des soucis dans le domaine du
logement de l'emploi de la santé de
l'éducation de la culture vous le voyez
dans les domaines des droits
fondamentaux
et vivre dans la grande pauvreté si on y
tombe pas du jour au lendemain on en
sort pas non plus du jour au lendemain
mais pourquoi je vous parle ainsi des
plus pauvres parce que je suis convaincu
que nous ne pouvons pas dans notre
société
laisser de côté plus de 2 millions de
personnes
imaginez que dans notre système scolaire
obligatoire
il y a de la maternelle au collège
3 millions d'enfants de jeunes qui
vivent dans une famille qui vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté et parmi eux
un million six vivent dans une famille
qui vit dans la grande pauvreté dans un
logement trop petit
dans un foyer d'hébergement
dans un hôtel dans un logement insalubre
mais pourquoi j'insiste tant
sur les plus pauvres
que je sais d'expérience que toute
mesure toute politique tout changement
dans notre société qui sera pensée
réfléchie à partir et avec les plus
pauvres
permettra de n'oublier personne imaginez
dans le domaine de l'éducation on
pourrait dire une pédagogie
qui part de l'enfant qui a le plus de
mal dans la classe pour faire réussir
tous les enfants
et qui ne pénalisent absolument pas les
enfants qui réussissent déjà très bien
faire réussir tout le monde en oubliant
personne
notre démocratie ne va pas bien
si nous voulons une société
unie
une société qui n'oublie personne une
société
où il y a la paix nous devons éradiquer
la grande pauvreté
vivre dans la grande pauvreté
pour les personnes qui le vivent au
quotidien c'est subir des humiliations
c'est être rejeté c'est être regardé de
manière différente des autres et le
ressentir profondément dans son corps
dès le plus jeune âge
mais je veux témoigner ici
de ces personnes qui vivent dans la
grande pauvreté de leur ténacité de leur
courage de leur envie de faire changer
les choses
parce que sachez que dans notre pays et
dans d'autres pays dans le monde parmi
dans notre pays parmi les deux millions
de personnes qui vivent dans la grande
pauvreté il y en a qui décide de devenir
militant
militant pour faire changer les choses
pour faire bouger les choses autour
d'eux pour aller chercher d'autres qui
sont encore plus enfouis que même dans
la misère dans la grande pauvreté
militant pour aller dire aux enseignants
de leurs enfants combien leurs enfants
doivent pouvoir réussir comme les autres
à l'école combien ils doivent être
écoutés comme les autres à l'école
militant
parce qu'ils veulent que notre société
n'oublie personne
c'est ainsi
qu'il le dise qu'il le vivent
et c'est ainsi que nous le dit Elisabeth
qui vit dans la grande pauvreté et qui
nous dit le plus dur quand tu vis dans
la misère c'est le mépris
qu'il te traite comme si tu ne valais
rien
qu'il te regarde avec des goûts jusqu'à
te traiter comme un ennemi nous et nos
enfants nous vivons cela chaque jour
cela nous fait mal nous humilie nous
fait vivre avec la peur et la honte
pour des centaines de milliers d'enfants
de jeunes vivre dans la grande pauvreté
dans notre pays
c'est vivre le conflit de loyauté
qui les empêche de rentrer dans les
apprentissages à l'école qui les empêche
d'oser apprendre d'oser comprendre tout
ce qui leur est proposé à l'école
conflit de loyauté parce que de manière
inconsciente il bloque les
apprentissages dans leur tête pour ne
pas trahir leurs parents pour ne pas
trahir leur famille
alors nous sommes là pour faire un pas
de côté ensemble
nous pouvons éradiquer la grande
pauvreté chacune et chacun d'entre nous
et là
parce que je suis persuadé que nous
pouvons éradiquer la grande pauvreté
nous avons chacune et chacun d'entre
nous notre part là-dedans alors l'état
bien sûr à sa part
mais vous allez le voir je vais vous
donner quelques exemples et vous allez
comprendre que
voilà chacun à notre mesure chacune et
chacun à notre place nous pouvons faire
changer les choses dans notre société
vous savez lorsque vous allez acheter
votre baguette
ou tout autre trajet à pied
vous croisez
des personnes en grande difficulté
vous n'osez pas les regarder
à peine un regard et pourtant au bout de
quelques jours
si vous les regardiez
un peu plus avec un peu de bienveillance
et puis
au bout de quelques semaines
vous pouvez oser un bonjour
vous pouvez oser
une amorce de dialogue
mais vous pouvez aussi vous unir avec
d'autres personnes
parce qu'ensemble on est plus fort vous
unir pour oser faire respecter les
droits des personnes qui ne peuvent pas
faire valoir leur droit qu'il n'y arrive
pas je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
logement emploi etc
ensemble on est plus fort vous pouvez
vous unir à d'autres et puis dans votre
quartier dans votre village dans votre
entreprise
que sais-je
si vous changiez votre regard
et si vous preniez le temps prendre le
temps avec un T majuscule prendre le
temps d'oser regarder
ceux qui sont plus en marge
ceux qui n'osent pas prendre leur part
dans l'entreprise dans le village dans
le quartier
mais si vous allez les rencontrer
se connaître pour se reconnaître
alors les choses peuvent changer et puis
pour ceux qui ont des enfants dans
l'école
osez aller à la rencontre des parents
qui sont toujours un peu loin de la
sortie de l'école pour ne pas se montrer
oser aller parler simplement se dire
bonjour moi aussi je suis parents comme
vous mes enfants sont dans cette école
oser parler
des enfants qui sont un peu rejetés qui
sont mis de côté
mais vous savez il y a déjà dans notre
pays
des lieux où tout cela se fait les
possibles ils sont déjà là on en parle
pas assez
les possibles sont déjà là et je veux
vous donner un exemple assez concret
vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler
territoire zéro chômeurs de longue durée
une expérimentation qui se mène dans
notre pays depuis 6 ans maintenant
depuis six ans sur 10 territoires précis
on expérimente alors 10 territoires et
depuis un an déjà plus de 35 ou 40
territoires ont rejoint ces 10
territoires et sur ces territoires on
expérimente le fait
d'aller rencontrer toutes les personnes
qui sont au chômage depuis plus d'un an
de dialoguer avec elle
pour recenser avec elle et avec tous les
acteurs du territoire les entreprises
les élus les artisans les associatifs
tous
on se met tous ensemble pour réfléchir
quelles sont les emplois qu'ils ment qui
manquent sur ce territoire mais qui ne
vaut qui ne vont pas enlever des emplois
aux entreprises qui sont déjà là et on
en trouve
et on crée des entreprises à but
d'emploi pour embaucher ces personnes
qui sont au chômage en moyenne
en moyenne
depuis 7 ans
les personnes qui sont embauchées en
moyenne
vous imaginez ce que ça peut changer
dans la vie de quelqu'un qui est au
chômage depuis cet an je ne crois pas
qu'on imagine bien
sept ans de chômage et on retrouve un
emploi au CDI au SMIC à ton choisi alors
ça change pour ces personnes ça change
pour leurs enfants ça change pour le
territoire parce que on ose vivre
ensemble on se connaît mieux on change
les choses alors je vous le redis
chacune et chacun d'entre vous
vous pouvez éradiquer la grande pauvreté
je compte sur vous